[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de nuestra
salud para ello ya está conmigo en
directo américa más romeros a la mar
bienvenida a feliz martes muy buen día
vamos a hablar de venezuela una de las
noticias de nuestros noticieros el
colapso sanitario en ese país obligó a
muchos a buscar financiamiento en el
extranjero para poder costear los gastos
de salud de sus familiares incluso ellos
mismos así sí así es y esto pasa porque
en el país ahora mismo no se accede a
buenos tratamientos de salud no se
accede a medicamentos tampoco entonces
hay muchos que se ven obligados a
ingeniárselas de otras maneras volviendo
a un momento al puente de éste que
agradas ahora en el noticiero que se ha
vuelto a abrir el puente simón bolívar
recordemos que hay de hecho se habían
establecido muchos puntos de contrabando
de medicamentos que quizás vuelvan ahora
porque era la única manera que tenían
muchos venezolanos de adquirir
tratamientos o pastillas que no se
conseguían en el país y eso también pasa
porque los sistemas de salud están
desbordados a raíz de la crisis de
económica que sólo se ha agravado
también con la pandemia de covite 19 eso
obliga también a muchos profesionales de
la salud a empezar a ejercer por fuera
del sistema de salud público cobran y
mucho más también a la agencia reuters
de hecho recogió el testimonio de un
chico que se vio obligado a abrir una
plataforma de crowdfunding como de
financiación colectiva para poder
costear los gastos de sanitarios de su
madre que se había contagiado de kobe de
19 escuchemos lo que nos contaba
sólo cuatro horas de oxigenoterapia que
es nada más poner al oxígeno ningún otro
tipo de tratamientos fueron 500 dólares
o sea nada más el hecho de colocar
oxígeno que es algo de primeros auxilios
hoy por hoy constituye un gasto que
ningún venezolano se puede dar la
capacidad de responder de una manera tan
inmediata y eficaz y que obviamente
puede depender de la vida del paciente
esos son precios carísimos en cualquier
lugar del mundo raúl pero imagínate para
un venezolano promedio tú lo debes saber
bien lo sé lo sé porque muchísimos
amigos míos pues han estado también en
esa situación para costear los
tratamientos de sus familiares y pues
una situación complicada amar pero
cambiamos ahora de tema vamos a eeuu
grandes farmacéuticas y también
distribuidoras sufrieron un revés
judicial por la llamada crisis de los
opioides que tanto golpea a la sociedad
americana pues mucho vamos de situación
complicada situación complicada raúl son
varios juicios en ohio empezó uno contra
las distribuidoras así días y wal mart
que son de las más grandes del país por
distribuir indiscriminadamente estas
pastillas y hacerlas llegar al mercado
no es negro por otra parte nueva un
tribunal obligó a compañías como
cardinal health o mckesson corp a pagar
200 millones de dólares para que el
estado pueda costear los costes de esta
crisis de la salud pero hablemos bien de
qué se trata la crisis de los opioides
empezó cuando grandes farmacéuticas
empezaron a vender y también médicos
empezaron a prescribir pastillas contra
el dolor sin advertir bien de los
riesgos de adicción que suponían un
opioide por ejemplo es la morfina que
eso tiene un origen natural pero también
puede ser el fentanilo por ejemplo que
eso tiene un origen sintético y lo que
hacen es disminuir la percepción del
dolor aumentar la sensación de placer
precisamente eso es lo que los hace
adictivos incluso más que la heroína
repasemos las cifras de esta crisis de
salud se calcula que la crisis de los
opioides dejó medio millón de muertes
entre 1999 y 2019 sólo en eeuu que fue
el país más golpeado por esto también se
sabe que entre un 20 y un 30 por ciento
de las personas a quien les prescriben
este tipo de medicamentos terminan
abusando de la sustancia con
consecuencias devastadoras lo último el
último dato que sabemos un dato muy
impactante es que el 80% de los
consumidores de heroína en estados
unidos empezaron o tuvieron algún tipo
de relación con el consumo de opioides
de medicamentos contra el dolor
prescribimos de manera legal prescribir
dos por una persona profesional de la
salud es delicada la situación mar pero
ahora cambiamos nuevamente tema espero
que sea bueno hablemos de la pandemia
del coi 19 porque la agencia europea del
medicamento recomendó la tercera dosis
tan polémica de refuerzo contra el cob y
19no como justificaron esta decisión
marco decirte si es bueno pero en
cualquier caso empieza a ser un poco
clarificador la agencia de medicamentos
europea deja esa decisión a los estados
que ya han empezado a aplicar terceras
dosis pero bueno está esta recomendación
válida la decisión de muchos escuchemos
el comunicado de ayer
el comité de la ema ha concluido que una
dosis extra de las vacunas contra el cob
y 19 de facer 20 y modernas pueden ser
administradas a personas con sistemas
inmunes gravemente debilitados al menos
28 días después de su segunda dosis el
comité de la ema ha evaluado datos para
la vacuna de facer bayón tec que
muestran un aumento en los niveles de
anticuerpos con una dosis de refuerzo
aproximadamente 6 meses después de la
segunda dosis en personas de 18 a 55
años si te parece raúl revisemos los
datos sobre los cuales basaron esta
decisión es un estudio que presentó
pzifer tanto en eeuu como en europa que
concluye que el contagio la prevención
del contagio se elevó otra vez hasta el
95% con esta tercera dosis también se
sabe que el nivel de anticuerpos se
multiplicó por 4 en comparación con los
anticuerpos que tenían las personas
después de haber recibido la pauta
completa seis meses antes sin embargo
hay unos últimos datos que se publicaron
ayer también hechos públicos por la
agencia del medicamento en eeuu que se
sabe que la efectividad de la vacuna
podría caer hasta el 50 por ciento en la
prevención de contagios
es uno son unos datos hechos ya no de
manera de un estudio clínico sino con
población vacunada con miles de personas
y esa decisión es esa nueva información
podría haber afectado ampliamente en
estas decisiones tanto de eeuu como en
europa sin embargo recordemos la vacuna
sigue protegiendo de manera efectiva en
un 90% contra él cobit grave contra las
hospitalizaciones contra las muertes y
es precisamente por eso que entidades
como la organización mundial de la salud
siguen recomendando que primero se
distribuyan equitativamente antes de
empezar a aplicar dosis de refuerzo a la
población en general ni siquiera los
inmunodeprimidos sino a todo el mundo a
ti a mí a quien sea así es mari mejor
puedes tener la población mundial
vacunada que solamente unos pocos con
una tercera dosis porque así logramos la
tan anhelada y tan esperada inmunidad de
rebaño de rebaño
marc gracias por toda la información nos
vemos mañana con el médico además por
hablar de la salud